when most people think about paper they
think a sheet of white paper like this
but when scientists talk about papers
they think of something like this this
is one of mine an article describing
results done by my students and they
have some really catchy titles and the
title of this one and we were quite
proud of it it's real-time product
switching using twin catalyst system for
the hydrogenation of furfural
in supercritical co2 paper is a
description of your results your
discovery you can have a short paper
which is called a communication or
longer one which is a full paper and
it's published in a journal the journal
is published in paper form and also on
the internet and their whole different
variety of journals this one was
published in the journal Angewandte
Chemie means applied chemistry in german
and the most famous journal is nature
people get really excited if you publish
the paper in nature get us on the
university website may even get into the
national press but then they're equally
important results that are published in
much less well-known journals here's one
from Russia another one from Hungary but
publishing papers is really important
the success of a chemists career is
determined by the quality and the number
of papers that they publish and they're
needed so that other people can know
what they've done there's no point doing
science if you don't publish the results